[Music]
david is in albuquerque david what's up
how are you doing everyone say thank you
so much for everything you guys do
around first of all thank you how can we
help
yeah i apologize a little bit to cali
because when she first called i was so
excited she picked up i missed david my
question but it's pretty close okay um i
just finished baby step two i'm working
on baby step three
and i'm thinking i had to babysit 3b to
save her house and like i'm getting
stuck because i got my credit card still
over because i have a high credit score
and i don't know am i supposed to close
them
or keep them open to keep the credit
score up so i buy a house
it's a great question i'm confused yeah
it's a great question and i feel like
it's it's a topic that we tackle a lot
because
there has been this mindset right in our
culture that the credit score is
everything right and so in order to buy
a house you have to have a great credit
score if you want to have a great life
you have to have a great credit score so
if you remove debt from your life if you
close all your credit card accounts
which we do recommend by the way
and you say okay i'm done with debt
completely what happens well over 12 to
18 months your credit score is going to
go down to undetermined it's going to
basically go you're going to watch it
just go down down down but here's the
deal the only reason you need a credit
score is to go into debt and so we don't
believe in going into debt anymore
because you're debt-free but for a
mortgage it is the one type of debt we
won't yell at you for but you can get a
mortgage actually without a credit score
so it's a process called manual
underwriting so you have to be current
on your job for two years and you have
to be current on all of your bills so
you have to have evidence of you know
everything from electricity or cell
phone just proof that you pay bills on
time
for two years
and a mortgage company churchill
mortgage is one that we recommend but
they will actually underwrite you the
mortgage without a credit score but the
danger is is that if you're going into
this
they will pull your credit score when
you go to take out a mortgage so you do
have to make sure that it's the point
because if it is if it is a bad credit
score right not undetermined but it is
lowering they can pull that and that
will ding you so you do have to get to a
point where your credit score is not is
undetermined basically
and then they can start that process of
manual underwriting and the detail is
you have to have every single account
closed and a zero balance
zero balance and has to be closed
otherwise it's still showing his
activity and so it's still
plugging into
the fico score algorithm and it's going
to create a score
um and so like if you have one account
open and all the rest are closed and it
is zeroed you're going to show a low
score your your score's going to drop
and you don't want to do that and so if
you go well i'm just going to keep this
one well you're going to screw up this
whole idea so it's kind of an all or
nothing you either need to keep them all
open and keep playing the game the way
the culture does and the culture is
broken stupid or you can play the game
where you go all the way game on
scorched earth no credit score
no borrowing money except for a house
and we're doing manual underwriting and
every single account has to be closed
and a zero balance and it will take at
least six months after that for your
credit score to be
undeterminable or indeterminable or i
just like saying zero i know because
it's not zero you do say that i know but
i'm a zero it's not
we have no identity we don't exist
because we have zero no it is not a zero
credit card there's no such thing as a
zero credit score undetermined
it means i don't exist
that's what it means i don't really live
off the grid i'm a hollander
this is the ramsay show